good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have something special that when you
unleash it it will be able to change the
world so to help you on your journey
today's message is live your life to the
fullest over to you Oprah Winfrey what
drives you to keep working so hard you
could you know you and I are in the 60s
category and so when you're in your 60s
you know you've lived more than you're
gonna live yeah Mystikal ii so when you
realize you've lived more than you're
gonna live you can say why not relax a
little bit why not just ease up why have
you decided to even work harder than you
did before because I think David that
everybody you know the thing that works
for me all these years whether it was
the magazine or which I still have or
whether it was the show I could I
understood that there's a common
denominator in the human experience and
I want the same thing you want which is
the same thing you want and you want
what we all want is to be able to live
out the truest highest expression of
ourselves as a human being that doesn't
end until you take your last breath
what is the truest highest vision that
you hold for yourself no matter where
you are in your life there's always the
next level there's always the next level
to the last breath so I feel that I
always knew that I would get be done
with the show when I felt like oh I've
said as much as I could say here on this
platform and then how will I be used if
they were if there were a theme song to
my life Amazing Grace would be one of
them and keep on using me to use me up
would be another one
you know that bill with their song so I
feel that until you have used your value
as a human being you're not done I don't
think most people live their life to the
fullest I don't think people are even
close I don't think most people are even
anywhere close to live in their life to
the fullest I think most people are
waiting for the weekends to come can't
wait for that vacation to come if you
are counting down the days to your
vacation then in my view I think there's
something wrong with your life now
there's something wrong with vacations
and something wrong with weekends I love
spending time with my family I love my
weekends I love vacations when I go off
to vacations but the thing is you want
to be running towards something like a
vacation or a weekend or activities that
you have should be something you run
towards where for most people a vacation
or weekend is a running away from their
current life your job sucks your life
sucks and so you want to just go away
sit on the beach for two weeks and not
have to worry about anything that's not
great like if you get to only get off
for one or two weeks a year and then you
know you're looking forward to the
weekends and you're spending most of
your life doing work that you hate
that's not anywhere close to living your
life to the fullest most people don't
even know what living their life to the
fullest looks like and so if that's you
if you like dread the work that you're
doing you're in the wrong thing like you
got to go off and do something else
that's why having passion for your
business is the most important
ingredient to success because if you're
only chasing an opportunity you only
have some big goal you're not gonna do
the work to get there you'll see you do
anything whatever it takes right I'll do
whatever it takes to get there but you
won't because you're only motivated by
the goal where you have to enjoy the
daily process you have to actually enjoy
the work and again not every day is
amazing not every day is insanely
successful I don't wake up every day and
have the best day ever there's a lot of
crap you have to deal with being an
entrepreneur but net like I enjoy the
work I'm doing I enjoy making YouTube
videos for you guys I enjoy responding
to the comments I enjoy running tirana
dance salsa I enjoy helping build Lily
up to being entrepreneur I enjoy net the
work that I do and you need to do the
same thing in your business if you want
to come anywhere close
to live in your life to your fullest I
agree with Oprah and that there is no
end point like it's until your last
breath you're doing it because you love
to do it if you love doing the thing why
do you want to stop if you're looking
for finish line and you can't wait to
retire you're in the wrong thing if
you're counting down the days to your
retirement or the vacation the weekend
you are doing the wrong thing and you
need to stop ASAP to move to something
that you can look forward to there is no
final date it's ongoing it's forever its
lifetime it's to your last breath that
has to be the thing and if you don't
know what that is that's okay
explore search find it don't just sit on
your hands doing the same thing over and
over and over and over again because the
path to finding what that thing is for
you that you can live your fullest life
and enjoy the work that you're doing
does not come from sitting on the couch
and staying in the life that you hate
that's not how you find it you got to
get out there and explore I also applaud
Oprah for leaving The Oprah Winfrey Show
at the height of her career she had the
number-one talk show she had tons of
influence millions of people following
her and she decides to go out like she
wasn't an athlete that you're gonna fade
over time right it's not like her skills
were diminishing and she's gonna fall
off a cliff right you know if you're a
50 year old basketball player you can
have a hard time keeping up she was at
the height of her game when she decided
to quit and move on because she felt
like that part of her life was done
right she had said what she wanted to
say but she wasn't done she wasn't
retiring she was moving on just to the
next chapter and so I have a lot of
respect for her of quitting the thing at
the height of her career to then move on
and try something brand new and I did
the same thing with my business where I
had my website and that was the thing I
was all in on my website and now I
barely spent any of my time on my
website it's still there it's still a
business still have my team or growing
it but more of my effort is focused on
the YouTube channel a few guys 40 Diaz
Lilly mentoring and building her up the
other projects that I'm working on and
if I ever get sick of the YouTube
channel if I ever have to think oh I
gotta make youtube videos the Sox hate
it if that's ever my mindset going into
a filming day I have to
like I will move on I might sell the
channel or it just might stop it if you
get to that point right you got to be
able to move on there's something else
now thankfully for me and for you guys I
love I love this like I loved I want to
get better I want to drive forward I
want to hit the next goal I want to make
these videos even better even more
impactful for you guys but this may not
continue in 5 years in 10 years in 30
years you know I'm still gonna be doing
things to help inspire billion
entrepreneurs that may not be through
YouTube YouTube me not even be around
and that's okay like the minute you
start losing your passion for whatever
it is that you're doing you need to move
on you might be able to sell the thing
that you made right and give it to
somebody else or may not be big enough
to sell that's ok drop it and move on to
something else
as soon as you lose that passion for
whatever it is that you're doing you
need to move on and go find something
else
ASAP because the window is closing you
only have so much time on this planet
and you want to do something that's
meaningful and stop counting down the
day so the next weekend
the next vacation to your retirement day
so the question of day today is I'm
curious what is the thing that makes you
come alive most what do you love most
about the business that you started or
the business you want to start or
something in your personal life like
what is the thing that you wish you
could do all day long it makes you feel
the most alive what is that thing for
you leave it down the console though
really curious to find out I also want
to give a quick shout out to litrenta
George litrenta thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word I really really appreciate the
support and I hope you enjoyed it so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
and I'll see you guys again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso
let's pray so give me go
someone on a another interview was just
asking me hey you know back in the early
days you guys released an album almost
every year you know you've got like five
you know five albums in six years or
something and what happened you know
that was eight years since the last one
it's like dude there's a lot more life
to do you know there's a lot you know
vacations with families watching my kids
grow up you know touring a lot longer
than it used to be you know back in
those days we had this many songs and
this is how many gigs we can do and then
we're back in the studio so a lot is
happening in life and everyone in the
band is on the same page which is really
a great thing
we've all got kids and we've all got
other lives but we can't live without
Metallica man it's just something that
joins us you know were these friggin
four married guys that know more about
each other than anyone knows about us
maybe our wives if you come to the idea
of mortality once in a way it'll make
you depressed it will make you fearful
if you live with it every moment it will
make you absolutely exuberant in a life
because it is just this one thing that
this is not forever this is just for a
brief period of time and the more joyful
you are briefer it becomes if you're
ecstatic it will just vanish in no time
yes so if you want to stretch it you
need to make yourself truly miserable
otherwise it'll be just gone in no time
if you come to terms with this if you
live this way that every moment you
appreciate one thing and only one thing
because the most important thing in your
life is you're alive right now to be
alive fully alive 100% alive is the most
important thing because only if
something is 100% alive
can you make it EAL something beautiful